[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Thank you,
everyone, for taking the time
to join us today, both in
person and on the livestream.
I am so excited to
introduce you to Dr. Leigh
Thompson from the Kellogg
School of Business.
She has been a professor
there for many years
and has done a tremendous
amount of research
in the areas of negotiation,
collaboration, creativity,
and teamwork, which
in our daily lives
obviously are essential
to solving problems
and to helping to move
the company forward.
So when I heard that she
had a new book out that
was focusing
specifically on helping
teams and managers
solve problems
in new and creative
ways, I absolutely
wanted to have her
come and talk to us.
So without further
ado, Leigh Thompson.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Well,
good afternoon, everybody.
So this is the
title of the book--
"Stop Spending, Start Managing."
And I want to give a head nod to
my hyper-talented collaborator,
first author of the book--
this professor Tanya Menon
from The Ohio State University.
And here's the backstory.
So when I first
met Tanya, she was
working on this very
interesting project
that, believe it
or not, involved
a study of Fresh Choice Zoopa.
And Fresh Choice, as
you probably well know,
is a very trendy--
or was a very trendy--
West Coast salad buffet chain.
But they were faced with a
stale concept, sinking sales.
And they had their eye
on a very quirky Seattle
competitor called Zoopa.
And Zoopa had a completely
different model.
Instead of having
a buffet chain,
they had chefs at stations
engaging customers.
What's your point?
The point is that Fresh
Choice was all over Zoopa.
They were looking at
their best practices.
They were infiltrating
their different restaurants,
learning, learning, learning.
Eventually, they acquired Zoopa.
And then all of a sudden,
the learning stopped.
All the innovative ideas
that they initially
were very excited about,
they were dismissing.
So we thought, well,
this is kind of weird.
What explains that?
How can you be
all over something
and then drop it
like a hot potato?
Then I started telling Tanya
about this phenomenon that
was happening in some
of my executive classes.
And I kept thinking of this
crazy Woody Allen quote--
"I never want to
belong to any club that
would have me as a member."
I just wanted to find
a way to work that
into the conversation.
So I've had more than
one of my executives
in my management
classes say that they've
had a very strange experience
in their own companies.
They would have
ideas, they would
have insights that
would be dismissed
by their bosses,
leaders, upper managers.
And then in the case of
one woman in my class,
once she left her company,
started her own consulting
firm, her previous
company called her
and paid her four
times the money
that she ever would have asked
for for her original idea.
So it wasn't until
she became an outsider
that all of a sudden, her ideas
seemed to get more valuation
or traction.
So what we're going to do today
is we're going to talk about--
well, why is it the case that
sometimes what we're doing
doesn't seem to add
traction to solving
some of our internal problems?
So sometimes, our strengths
can lead us astray.
So what we're going
to do today is
we're going to talk about the
winner's trap, which really
comes out of this
Zoopa, Fresh Choice,
we overvalue
consultants' ideas where
we tend to see our
colleagues as competitors
and we devalue their ideas.
We're going to talk
about the expertise trap.
And that's where we get so
involved in our own domain
that we block learning
from other domains.
We're going to talk about my
favorite one, the agreement
trap.
So I'm a negotiation researcher.
And what I often
find is that people
are extremely uncomfortable
negotiating, especially
in unscripted situations.
So we're going to have
some fun with that.
Another favorite one
of mine is called
the macro-management trap.
The central idea is that we've
gotten the memo that we need
to empower others and delegate.
And then we take away
all the structure,
and we don't put
up any guardrails.
And then we're going
to talk a little bit
about the communication trap.
So armed with all
of our technology,
the signal-to-noise ratio
is starting to be a problem.
I don't expect you
to read all this.
But we did a survey with a
lot of different executives,
leaders, managers, et cetera.
And we had them basically
say how much money
do you spend each day on--
how much money do
you lose each day
when you are not
able to negotiate
a mutually beneficial outcome.
This is my favorite one.
How much money would
you say is involved
in unproductive
meetings-- so if you
think about what is the
value of your time, how
many meetings you're in.
We also asked a lot
of questions about
do you pay people to motivate
them to do routine work.
And we asked a lot of questions
about how much money do you
pay consultants versus
your own people.
And the bottom line numbers
really surprised us.
So on average--
these are hundreds
of people that
we're interviewing--
said that they spent over
$7,000 per line item per day.
If you add up the cost
of this wasted time,
if you add up all these
dimensions together,
there's a waste of
like a $144,000 a day,
and it turns out to
be $52 million a year.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to unpack some of
these hidden people problems.
And what we're
going to start with
is the winner's trap, which is
the basis of how we got started
in this whole enterprise.
And the idea here is that
motivated, results-driven
managers get things done.
A lot of us have been programmed
to be action oriented,
take charge.
Sometimes, though, we may see
our colleagues as competitors.
Now, what I'm
going to do next is
I'm going to talk to you
about a research study.
And I just want you to
make some predictions.
So here's the research study.
So what Professor
Menon and myself
did is we wanted to
compare how people--
managers, people
who have real jobs--
react to good ideas--
in other words,
innovative ideas--
authored by internal people,
who are their colleagues,
versus the exact
same idea allegedly
authored by an outsider.
Maybe it would be a competitor.
Maybe it would be somebody
outside the company.
And I'm just curious--
what would be your intuition?
These people are reacting
to the exact same idea.
The only difference
is that I either
think it's been authored
by a colleague of mine,
or I think it's been authored
by maybe a competitor of mine.
What would be your intuition?
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Deborah.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Deborah.
Deborah is saying I wish you
wouldn't have call on me.
So Deborah, what would
be your intuition?
I've told you we
have this theory.
AUDIENCE: The external.
LEIGH THOMPSON: The external.
Do you have any intuitions why?
Why is it that we do that?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
I don't have a good theory.
LEIGH THOMPSON: But you
seem really quick to think
we think it's the external.
So something about-- OK.
So this is what we found.
Deborah is spot on.
So what we did here-- and
I want to explain this--
is we said, well,
how willing would you
be to learn from this
really cool, novel idea.
And we found that--
again, holding the nature,
substance of the
idea constant, we
are much more likely to want
to learn from outsiders' ideas
than insiders' ideas.
And again, I keep
on driving home--
we're holding the
idea itself constant.
And then we ask people, well--
I asked the same question
that I asked Deborah.
Why do you think this is?
We asked a lot of questions.
But when it came to
are you concerned
that you might lose some
status in your organization
if you really followed Deborah's
idea, that's when people said,
yes, we think that
that could be the case.
So we did a followup
study, and we
found that managers
allocate 42% more budget
money to learn about
outsider innovation
the same way that Zoopa--
the same way that Fresh
Choice did with Zoopa.
But they believed that they were
36 more likely to lose status.
So then what we did is we
had to try to be good social
scientists, and we
had to say, look,
if we're going to show something
bad about human behavior that
we de-value-- our
colleagues' ideas--
as good social
scientists, we should
try to be able to repair this.
What's the fix?
What's the Band-Aid?
And so we hypothesized
that maybe what's going on
is this that people in
companies and organizations
get into micro-competitions.
Every day, I'm trying to
be smarter than Deborah.
I'm trying to be
smarter than Nicky.
And so if we can get people out
of these micro-competitions,
maybe they'll realize,
well, Nicky really
has a really cool
idea, and it's not
going to cause me
to lose status.
So what we did is we did a very
simple research investigation.
We had some people call
to mind specific personal
accomplishments that they
themselves had achieved.
And other people-- we
didn't tell them to do this.
And what we found
is that the people
who recalled a personal
accomplishment when
they heard about
Deborah's fantastic idea--
they said, of course I
want to learn from Deborah.
Of course I want to
acquire that knowledge,
and of course I'll use it.
If they didn't recall a personal
accomplishment-- no recall--
they were less
likely to do that.
So the takeaway message is that
we need to widen our aperture.
We need to get away from the
micro, daily competitions
and realize there is talent
all around me that I can use,
and it doesn't mean
that, in some sense,
I'm going to be a loser.
So I want to ask
you the equivalent
of a managerial Rorschach test.
Let's imagine that these
two people work together.
They're on the same team.
And I want you to imagine
that the young woman we
see here is the boss, or at
least the older gentleman
here reports up to you.
Any hypotheses about--
and let's suppose
they're discussing a
very important project.
Any hypotheses about what
their professional relationship
is like?
This is an open-ended question.
Can I call on you?
Yes.
What's your first name?
AUDIENCE: Sarah.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Sarah.
OK, Sarah.
What do you think
is going on here?
AUDIENCE: So the lady is the--
SPEAKER: The lady is the boss.
He reports up to her.
How does he feel
about this whole--
they're discussing a project.
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
Maybe he feels undervalued.
He may be more experienced.
LEIGH THOMPSON: He's
got more experience.
You can look at
him and tell that.
Anybody else have a--
thank you.
Anybody else have an intuition
about how he might feel?
AUDIENCE: Like he knows better.
SPEAKER: Like he knows better.
So I got very
interested in this.
You guys know I teach
full-time MBA students.
And I cannot tell you how many
times I've had a very young
28-year-old, 27-year-old
MBA student--
male or female-- say one of
the most uncomfortable things
about my previous job
before coming to b-school
was that I had older
people on my team
who were threatened by me.
I was their boss.
So in other words, they walk
around feeling like I'm young,
I'm talented, and
older people have
a hard time dealing with me.
And we thought, oh my gosh.
What a problem to have.
I don't have that
problem, but they do.
So what we did is we
thought, well, we've
got to study the dang thing.
So what we did is we set up a
situation where we had managers
on project teams estimate how
much they threatened others,
because they're so
brilliant, and so talented,
and so accomplished.
But we also asked them,
well, how threatened are you.
And so I'm kind of curious.
I'm going to call on some
of my folks over here.
What's your first name?
AUDIENCE: Andrew.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Andrew.
Do you have a hypothesis about
what we're going to find?
How threatened-- people have
to say how threatened they are
and how threatening
other people see them
in terms of their
prowess and talent.
You have that intuition?
AUDIENCE: People are probably
uncomfortable with admitting
that they feel threatened.
SPEAKER: Say it again.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
that they're threatened.
SPEAKER: I think Andrew
is really on to something.
And he said-- I'm
going to repeat it
for acoustical
reasons-- he said people
are uncomfortable admitting
how threatened they might be.
Andrew, that's
exactly what we found.
I think you have a career
as a social scientist
if you're interested.
So what we did-- ignore
this junk for a minute.
We asked people, look,
you're on this project team.
How much do you
threaten others just
because you're so bad ass
and so talented, et cetera?
And they said, oh, my
gosh, I'm almost a five
on a five-point scale.
Because I've got all
this going on for me,
and it's just hard for people
to take so much of my greatness.
When we flip the question,
Andrew's theory holds.
We asked them, well,
how threatened are you
by all these fantastic
colleagues of yours.
Oh, I'm about a 3.26.
So in other words,
then we started
to become very interested in
this whole threat immunity
thing.
In other words, I
don't get ruffled
that other people have a hard
time taking my greatness.
And I'm overdramatizing here.
So then we decided to
really dial this up,
and then we published
this crazy paper called--
based upon this bumper
sticker that we saw--
"Don't Hate Me
Because I'm Beautiful.
Hate Me Because I'm Young,"
which is the snarkiest thing
that anybody could say.
We don't hate you at all
because of those things.
You're just annoying.
And what we found--
and I want you to
think about what
Andrew said a few minutes ago.
What we found is to the extent
that we're walking around
in this little ego bubble,
where I'm so talented
and I know it type of
thing, and other people
have a hard time
taking my greatness--
two things happen which really
can cost an organization
a lot of value.
One thing that
happens is that people
start to dumb themselves down.
Actually, about 48%
of people said, well,
I've decided to hold
back a little bit,
because I'm sure that people
will fall apart once I
start to speak my greatness.
And then we also found out
that this whole threat immunity
bubble can hurt relationships.
In other words,
people don't feel
as collaborative and
connected on a team.
So again, the key here
is that people are not
that threatened by you.
So we need to really speak
up and offer what we have.
Now what I want to
do is I want to talk
about-- question, Nikki.
AUDIENCE: What about the
theory of imposter syndrome?
LEIGH THOMPSON: OK.
So the great question was, what
about the imposter syndrome,
which is, oh, my
gosh, I'm the idiot.
And sooner or later,
the organization
is going to realize that
I shouldn't be here.
I think that that is alive
and well and kicking.
But what we don't know
is what is the base
rate of the imposter syndrome.
I think that a lot of times--
at least qualitatively
speaking-- a lot of newcomers--
like, for example, PhD
students to programs--
have a little bit of
that imposter syndrome.
Once they finally pass the
preliminary examinations,
they dust themselves off.
So I think that the
imposter syndrome
is alive and well and kicking.
But I don't think it's got as
big of a base rate, incidence
rate as this one.
So I'd love to do a study
where you take people
who have this threat immunity,
put them in the same room
as somebody who has the imposter
syndrome, and see what happens.
So I'm going to
switch gears, and I
want to talk about
this expertise trap.
And the whole idea here--
and I've done my own
little crossing out here--
is that domain expertise
is essential these days.
We're really
focused on let's get
people who are hyper-talented
in what they do.
And then let's
hopefully have them
cross-pollinate
with other people.
But I'm very interested in
this whole idea of where
do you get really cool ideas.
And so I'm going to show you--
I wish I would have
done this study.
I didn't do this study.
But I'm going to tell
you about this study,
because I think it's great.
So this study was done by
O'Creevy and his colleagues.
And what they did is they had
two groups of people sitting
in front of computers, like
a Bloomberg stock trading
terminal.
And they were told, look,
there's a line moving,
numbers updating.
And they said, look, experiment.
Play around with the buttons.
See if you can figure
out what manipulates
the movement of the line.
Group 1 thought that
they were, quote,
very successful in figuring out
how the buttons move the line.
And these are Wall
Street traders.
Group 2, which
were random people
without a financial
background, quickly
realized there is no
relationship between me
pressing, in some
sense, the lever
and what is happening
on the line.
So the takeaway message that
I think O'Creevy was going for
is that sometimes,
experts in a domain
see things that might not
be there, or in some sense,
overestimate their expertise.
So my next question
for you guys is
going to be where do you
get your innovative ideas.
Because I'm very
interested in this.
And I wanted to
tell you a story.
I work with chief
security officers.
I know that sounds like an
interesting group to work with,
but that's who I work with.
And they told me
this great story.
I said, where are you guys
getting your next innovations?
You're dealing with all
kinds of really challenging--
cyber threats, all kinds of--
bioterrorism.
There's all kinds
of stuff going on.
They told me this great story.
They said that recently, they
did an off site at a zoo.
And I said, come again?
What are you guys
doing at the zoo?
And they said, Leigh,
animals of every species
are under constant threat.
And different species
have different ways
of protecting themselves
against threat.
They said, we wanted
to learn about as many
of these different
methods as possible.
Because one of those ideas,
as crazy as it sounds,
could open up an
innovation for us.
Now, that sounds crazy.
But I recently had a woman in
my class who, believe it or not,
was designing the
suits that people--
that health care
professionals have
to wear dealing
with Ebola patients.
This is weird.
And they're designing
these suits.
And you have to
stay in them all day
because the patients
are coming in,
and they're very comfortable.
And they said, guess
who we teamed up with?
I said, I can't even imagine.
She said, well, women
who are getting married
have to stay in the dang
wedding dress the whole day.
So they got their greatest
innovation by, in some sense,
going way outside their
domain, looking at-- well,
let's talk about
the wedding dress.
It has to look gorgeous, but
it's got to be comfortable.
You've got to stay
in it the whole day.
So my question to you is--
what's your first name?
AUDIENCE: Ed.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Ed.
Ed is thinking, oh, my gosh.
She's coming for me.
And this is a question for Ed
and anybody else in the room.
If you can think of your last
cool idea or innovative idea,
however large or small--
can you think of
a situation where
it came from outside
of a typical domain,
like maybe a movie,
a wedding dress?
AUDIENCE: My toddler.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Say it more.
She's where I get a
lot of ideas about life
because I try to make her
stop doing crazy things.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Right.
So you're trying to keep the
toddler like, wait a minute,
we don't do things this way.
So were you working on
a particular problem,
Nikki, where the toddler said,
oh, I can do it with a balloon,
or something?
AUDIENCE: No, but that's just--
or randomly just talking to
people in the micro-kitchen,
we'll get an idea about how
to [INAUDIBLE] 3D printer.
And then if you're
recycling, then you
should just be able to recycle.
LEIGH THOMPSON: First of all,
I love the fact that you're
the micro-kitchen, because
we can start to now talk
about collisionable
hours, running
into people who
aren't necessarily
in my domain of expertise.
And even though they haven't
had all the years of experience
you might have had, you
get a really cool idea.
Anybody else have a--
same, from the toddler?
From the toddler.
AUDIENCE: A couple of ideas
that I look at other industry--
like, for example, how do
you [INAUDIBLE] process.
For example, we're
a software company.
Then looking at the
pharmaceutical company,
they may have a similar
process that I can borrow from.
LEIGH THOMPSON:
Oh, that's great.
I love-- what's your first name?
AUDIENCE: Sam.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Sam.
All right.
So Sam is saying, I am in the
computer software industry.
But maybe they're
doing something
in pharma that has a really
cool process where we can beg,
borrow, and steal that idea.
So now I want you to
predict something.
This is some research I did
with my colleague [INAUDIBLE].
I love to study teams.
Heather knows how interested
I am in your teens at Google.
We did a very controlled
study in which--
and it's all about
innovation and creativity--
some groups stayed
intact, meaning
that you work with
the same people,
and you didn't
change up membership.
You're working on the same
problem, innovation problem.
Other groups stayed intact
except at periodic times.
What your fist name?
AUDIENCE: Boris.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Boris.
Except at certain periods,
Boris would come into the group,
and somebody else would leave.
So it was what we
called open groups.
So in other words, we're
about 75% to 85% intact,
but we're having
some people go and--
it's not a total changeup.
It's just what we
called an interloper.
And then they had to do
a brainstorming task.
What's your hypothesis, Boris?
Who's more innovative, the
open or the closed groups?
AUDIENCE: The open groups.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Open groups.
And why would that--
let's imagine everybody--
it's not like you're inviting
in Einstein or anything,
but say more.
AUDIENCE: I would say, for
example, when I do software,
I like to think
about it like how
a user who has no idea
about my processes
and all the stuff that we do,
how they can just quickly take
it and use it without
all the knowledge,
advanced knowledge of
what we were doing.
LEIGH THOMPSON: OK.
So in other words, that's where
the interloper, the newcomer
might be a great pair
of eyes to test that.
Anybody else have a similar--
what's your name
in the very back?
AUDIENCE: Brian.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Brian.
Sorry.
What's your hypothesis about
the open or closed group?
Because I think Boris
is on to something,
but maybe you have
a different opinion.
AUDIENCE: No.
I feel like getting those
fresh eyes on problems
is always helpful.
And I try to encourage
that in my own teams.
LEIGH THOMPSON: And
sometimes, it's hard to do.
So here's what we found.
We found-- and this
is holding constant
the talent and training
level in the group.
So it isn't like we brought
in certain gifted people.
It was more that we just
simply reshuffled a few members
in existing groups.
We reshuffled.
And what we found is
that the open groups
generated more ideas.
And our fancy word
for that is fluency.
They just have a greater
proportion of per-person ideas
in a fixed amount of time.
And the open groups
showed more flexibility,
which is our name for how many
different ideational shifts.
How were they able to pivot?
And so that was very
interesting for us,
because we found that
a lot of times, teams
like to stay intact.
And the idea of inviting
in an interloper
could be threatening to
the team's performance.
So now we're going
to talk a little bit
about the communication trap.
And here's the
nature of the trap.
So we're armed with
communication technology
that transcends time and place.
But the trap is that this very
prevalence of communication--
my iPhone, and I have email,
and I have FaceTime, all this--
that it might hurt the
signal-to-noise ratio.
So now-- don't look
at this junk yet.
Now I have a question for you.
So you have been
called to facilitate
an off-site by, let's
say, an unnamed company.
And the unnamed company
is saying, Boris,
we're having an off-site.
We're going to have about
30, 35, 40 people there.
We really need to dig deep,
discuss certain issues.
But we're very concerned that
certain alpha dominant people
might monopolize the meeting.
Now you can look at the
crazy stuff up here.
So when you do some research--
let's take a typical
eight-person group,
and let's suppose
we're videotaping
in a very unobtrusive
fashion who's dominating.
The most alpha, dominant person
in a typical eight-person group
does about 42% of
all the talking.
Stated another way,
if the faculty meeting
is a 100 minutes
long, this person
is talking for 42 minutes.
The second most
alpha-dominant person--
wow, 16%.
And the rest of us are
the disenfranchised.
This phenomenon is called the
uneven communication problem,
and it's almost like a
law of group behavior.
So this is where you come in.
This unnamed company--
what's your first name?
AUDIENCE: Dimitri.
LEIGH THOMPSON: [INAUDIBLE]?
LEIGH THOMPSON: Dimitri.
Dimitri, we really need you.
We have 35, 40 people, so we're
deathly afraid that there's
going to be one, two, or three
people who really dominate
this off-site.
And Dimitri, money
is not an object.
What can you do to
make sure that we don't
have this uneven communication?
And we're going to
ask other people, too.
AUDIENCE: So we may split all
those people to smaller groups.
LEIGH THOMPSON: I
love Dimitri's idea.
He's saying let's get away
from the 35-person gang.
Why don't we maybe have five
or six clusters of groups
so that we can have some
simultaneous participation?
I love that.
Other ideas?
What's your first name again?
AUDIENCE: Caroline.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Caroline.
Money is not an object.
AUDIENCE: In addition to
the small group thing,
maybe mandating that each
person has a time to talk
or going around.
LEIGH THOMPSON: I like that.
Caroline?
I like what Caroline is saying.
She's saying she's not going to
be passive about participation.
She's going to say maybe we
need to hear from certain people
that we haven't heard from.
Maybe we're going to have to
play bad cop with some people.
Anybody else?
So far, I love these ideas.
What's your first name?
AUDIENCE: Alina.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Alina.
AUDIENCE: So what
about having laptops,
tablets, whatever so that people
can send in their responses
anonymously.
And that way, you can't
trigger responses.
Nobody feels shy.
For all they know, you could
just be sitting here texting.
LEIGH THOMPSON: I
love Alina's idea.
She's saying maybe
the way to get
more equalized participation
is to eliminate the need
to dominate the verbal floor.
So I think what
Alina is saying--
she's suggesting a strategy
called brain writing.
Alina, had you heard of that?
I think you have a future
as a social scientist, too.
So we're going to
get to brain writing.
One company that I
know deals with this
by taking a couple
of decks of cards
and passing out an equal
number of cards to everybody.
I don't know-- maybe
five, six, eight cards.
Every time you say
something, you play a card.
And once your hand is
empty, you zip it up.
So you have to think, oh, am
I going to play my card here.
Some companies use timers,
like the old Wizard of Oz.
Once you've set a certain
number of minutes,
some people use facilitators.
I think Caroline would
make a great facilitator.
And then Alina has
said, why don't we
stop all the verbal domination.
Why don't we give everybody
a laptop or the equivalent,
and have them be able
to post their ideas?
So anybody in this room--
Dimitri, anybody ever
heard of brain writing?
It's not a trick question.
OK, good.
OK, I got Sam right here.
So brain writing is
not brainstorming.
I love brainstorming.
I've done a lot of
research on it myself.
But brain writing
is even better.
Brain writing is the
simultaneous generation
of written ideas by
individuals in a group.
And when I use this
technique, I have two rules--
no guessing and no confessions.
I'm not exactly
sure what she means.
Let's say I was working with
a corporate travel group.
And let's say that
they were trying
to brainstorm ways of using
social media to increase
corporate travel sales.
Let's just say that.
Let's say there were 30 people.
I brought in 1,500 index
cards, three-by-five cards.
I passed them out.
And I said, for the next 10
minutes, complete silence.
Everybody write down
all of your ideas
for this corporate
social media travel idea.
If you have 12
ideas, take 12 cards.
If you have 15 ideas--
you guys are with me?
So in other words, every
single idea of yours
is on its own card.
Don't sign your
name on the card.
That's the no confessions part.
Because when we tape the cards
on the wall, step three--
after writing
individually, posting--
step three is everybody
gets five post-it notes,
and you vote for the five
ideas you find most exciting.
And you can't say, well,
I bet Alina's idea is
the third from the left.
No.
You cannot try to
guess who said what,
because it's a
meritocracy of ideas.
I don't know whose
idea I'm voting for,
but I think that
that's cool, and that
will move our project forward.
When we did this strategy,
the group generated 228 ideas
in 10 minutes.
According to the
research, if we were
to have gone around
the proverbial table,
we never would have gotten
past the second idea,
especially if it came from
the chief marketing officer.
Because then everybody
would have been saying,
sounds good to me.
Now let me talk about some data.
So what we have here
is a meta-analysis,
which means you
take several dozen--
almost approaching
100-- research studies.
And then let's
compare brainstorming,
which is, in some sense,
a verbal free-for-all.
I love those.
Everybody say anything
about a certain project
without regard to
feasibility or expense.
And then let's compare
it to brain writing.
And let's have-- what's
your first name again?
AUDIENCE: Dan.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Let's have
Dan start us off and say--
actually, let's get a
neutral, third-party judge
who's blind to whose
ideas she's evaluating,
and she just kind of calls it.
Dan, do you have an intuition
or a hypothesis in terms
of quantity and
quality as to which--
where you'd put your money?
AUDIENCE: Well, I've never
heard of brain writing,
but I'm sure it's better.
Because some people
are reluctant to talk.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Right.
Maybe you'll judge me.
And I'm an imposter, anyway.
AUDIENCE: You're
doing it anonymously.
LEIGH THOMPSON: We're
doing it anonymously,
because I enforce
that no guessing rule.
So Dan, am I hearing
you correctly
that you would say that the
brain writing groups would
have greater quantity
and greater quality
than our brainstormers?
I think you have a career
as a social scientist, too.
No, I do.
I've never had anybody come
out of the gate with that.
Well, Dan is exactly right.
So when you look at this,
the brain writing groups
are generating about 2 and
1/2 times the volume of ideas.
Now, maybe they're crappy ideas.
But then when you have a
neutral, third-party judge
who's statistically blind
to whose ideas he or she is
evaluating, there's a
significantly greater
percentage of those ideas
deemed to be of value.
So to me, the
takeaway is when we
are on the hunt for innovation,
the last thing we want to do
is have barriers to entry.
So that's why I
love Alina's idea.
Now, speaking of-- yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Question about that.
So it's the product
of those that's
the most important thing.
It's the number of ideas
times-- the number of good ideas
that we want to maximize.
LEIGH THOMPSON: In the end.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
But one of the
things that we find
is that too often, groups
want to put that quality
criterion out there.
And we want them--
at least upstream in
the innovative process--
to be ready to put the
rubble on the table.
So what I tell a lot of
my students and executives
is the way you're going
to get to dime and a ruby,
a sapphire, and a rare gem
is to have a lot of ideas
and have some
principle of selection.
So the answer is yes.
But a lot of times, groups
so quickly go to quality.
And that's, again, what
we study in this book.
I've been trained
to be high quality.
I've been trained to
rip ideas to shreds.
But there's always a time
and a place for that.
We must be very
obsessed with off-sites.
And I'm going to have you
make a prediction here, too.
So our observation that
management off-sites often
have brag sessions--
and that's not the words
they use, but they often
have periods of time
where people stand
up and they talk
about a lot of great
things that they've done.
And we started to
wonder whether talking
about a self-enhancing
moment, a moment of pride,
versus an embarrassing
incident might help creativity.
So we did a controlled
research study.
We actually did
this two times, one
with teams of senior
leaders and another time
with a group of
much younger people.
And we had them, right
before brainstorm,
either share a moment of pride
or a moment of embarrassment.
And I'm very interested in what
would be your predictions here.
Sam, what do you think?
You're a social scientist.
And it's going to be all about
how many ideas that they create
without regard to feasibility.
AUDIENCE: My guess would
be that the one bragging.
LEIGH THOMPSON: The bragging?
OK.
So the bragging folks--
maybe it's because-- OK.
You think differently.
What do you think, Heather?
AUDIENCE: So I think the
embarrassing incident.
Because a lot of
times, people are
afraid that their idea may
not have enough quality.
And so by having
somebody who they
see as being successful
showing that they have not
set successful limits but
were still successful,
will free people up to
share more freely, I think.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Wow.
I love your intuition there.
So in other words, if I have
the chief marketing officer,
the senior vice president,
whoever it might be,
talk about an
embarrassing moment--
a foible, a flaw--
then I'm not going to
hold back on my idea.
Because what can be worse
than what you just said?
So that's pretty much exactly
what we found, Heather.
And the way to read
these crazy data
is that we've cooked up
a creativity score which
is a combination of
fluency, flexibility, volume
times quality.
And what we found
is that the groups
who recounted an embarrassing
moment had more ideas--
fluency is our fancy word
for volume per person ideas--
and they made more pivots.
They experimented with
different kinds of ideas
than the self-enhancer.
So now what I do is every
time I lead an off-site,
I actually have people
share an embarrassing story.
And it seems weird.
But pretty soon,
everybody is laughing,
exactly the way
Heather predicted.
And all of a sudden,
the guard is down,
and we can start putting a lot
of things out on the. table.
So I want to talk about
the macro-management trap.
And the whole idea
here is that managers
are told to empower others, but
sometimes, they remove too much
in the name of empowerment.
And by the way, if I hear one
more person, one more company
say our rule is that we have
no rules, I will scream.
Because those studies
have been done.
If you take away all the
rules, people freeze in place.
Because it's like being at the
dinner table, and I'm not sure
which fork to pick up.
Because there are
no rules, so I'm
waiting to see
what Caroline does.
And Caroline is waiting
to see what I do.
And no one is doing anything.
So one of the
things that we have
witnessed over the
year-- and I apologize.
This is shock value,
and I apologize.
So we're very
interested in teams.
Heather knows how
interested I am in teams.
And I'm interested
in team composition,
and I'm interested in team size.
And we have found,
in our own research,
that the average team
size-- this is self-report--
has increased over the years.
The current average team
size in our database
is about 13 people.
And some of you might
be saying, well,
that sounds like a nice number.
What's wrong with 13 people?
Well, I will tell you that big
teams are less cohesive, less
satisfied, less cooperative,
and they have lower per-person
productivity.
There's something about having
the smallest number of people
necessary to
accomplish the task.
I'm going to share some of
my favorite rules of thumb.
Our friend Jeff Bezos, Amazon--
you guys have heard this.
Our Seattle people
have heard this.
He has a two pizza rule.
If he cannot feed his team with
two pizzas, maybe it's too big.
And these are not Chicago
deep-dish style pizzas.
That would feed
several football teams.
AT&T, phone company-- maybe
seven plus or minus two people,
like a phone number.
SAP restricted their 20,000
employees to teams of 8 to 12.
And that's why I really like
Dimitri's idea, a few moments
back, of let's split up
this 30-person group.
Because if I am not providing
some guardrails as the leader,
our teams are going to become--
we have a recent
paper called "What's
Your Team BMI," how many
people are on your team.
Now, I'm very interested,
being at a tech company,
to talk about
communication technology.
Rule number one up here
we do at dinner parties,
but we may not do
this at the office.
It says when meeting face to
face, put away technology.
Why?
Why would I want to
put away my technology
if I was having a
meeting with Dan?
Why on earth would I do that?
Maybe I want to be able
to get a phone call.
Any--
AUDIENCE: You're
only half engaged.
LEIGH THOMPSON: I'm
Because maybe this
thing is going to ring.
So what happens to
the relationship
that Dan and I might have
as colleagues when there's
a cell phone on the table,
turned off, between the two
of us.
Do you have a
hypothesis about that?
AUDIENCE: A lower
level of trust.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Absolutely.
So they did a recent
study where they
had two people communicating.
There was a
turned-off cell phone
versus, I think, in another
situation, a spiral notebook.
There's lower trust,
less cohesion.
So that's why we say
put away the technology.
I think that this
is interesting.
The CEO of SuccessFactors
said two new rules--
stop the blind carbon copying.
So in other words,
BCC is not allowed.
And if anyone else complains
about a team member,
he brings them into the loop.
I'm also very interested
on email boundaries.
One unnamed consulting firm
that I have worked with
says you do not send emails
to team members before 7:00 AM
or after 5:00 PM, and
certainly not on the weekends.
You're nodding your head.
Nikki, good rule?
AUDIENCE: We tried to
have it on our last team.
LEIGH THOMPSON: You tried?
It sounds like a
past tense statement.
You tried to have that.
Because some of us just
can't stop ourselves.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: There's two
things about that.
One is time zones mess with
that, make it difficult.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Time zones mess
with that, especially outside
of the United States.
AUDIENCE: And also,
technology makes it--
doesn't make it
easier to do this.
Sometimes I have
ideas off hours,
and the technology
doesn't make it easy
for me to put that
down and not send it.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Right.
So there could be
some hurdles for that.
I do think it's interesting
that one organization that we
work with has--
this is a little bit different
than what you're saying,
but it's something
that I do myself--
nothing but good news and
updates delivered via email.
In other words, if
you have a problem,
do this or knock on my door.
So I'm kind of curious.
What is your intuition about--
why would they say nothing
but good news and
updates via email?
Why would they say that, Alina?
AUDIENCE: Quicker
response rates, people
actually check the emails.
LEIGH THOMPSON:
Well, what happens
if I send you an
email saying I really
don't like what you said
in the faculty meeting,
and I would kindly
remind you to--
AUDIENCE: It's very
passive aggressive.
[INAUDIBLE]
LEIGH THOMPSON: It's
very passive aggressive.
What do you guys think of that?
Remind me of your first name.
AUDIENCE: Sarah.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Sarah,
what do you think about it?
Was that a good rule to
have, or it it please, just--
AUDIENCE: I feel like
it's common sense
to deal with issues
more face-to-face.
There's a lot of hidden messages
people read into emails.
LEIGH THOMPSON: And
what do we know--
what's your intuition about
how social behavior changes
when communicating via
information technology
or email?
Nikki?
AUDIENCE: If the rules
was nothing but good news
or updates delivered
via email, you're
forcing the assumption
that everyone
has positive intents if it's
coming through an email,
so it takes a lot of the
miscommunication out of intent
from emails.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Good.
Right.
Absolutely right.
So people don't have to
deconstruct the email.
And we also know
about social behavior
that when you send
me a neutral message,
I interpret it as negative.
When you send me a
negative message,
then I tend to flame back.
So I've adopted this
strategy in my own life.
I have a problem
with something, I
am going to try to have a
synchronous communication.
So now I want to talk about, in
some sense, my favorite trap,
which is the agreement trap.
And I want to share one
of my favorite quotes
by Eldridge Cleaver, who said
"too much agreement kills
a chat."
I'm dying to know.
Boris, you're
always here for us.
What does he mean by this?
And by the way, not only
what does he mean, but is
that a good assumption to make?
What does he mean, too much
agreement kills a chat?
AUDIENCE: Sounds like people
don't challenge each other.
LEIGH THOMPSON: They don't
challenge each other.
So why don't I want to live in a
world where I'm not challenged?
It actually might be
a lot more convenient.
I'm tired of being challenged.
AUDIENCE: You're
not going to grow.
LEIGH THOMPSON: I'm
Right?
What's that, Alina?
AUDIENCE: Nothing new will come.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Nothing
new will come up,
because I'll play it safe.
And you'll play it safe.
And then we're going
to get bypassed.
So how do I set up--
I don't know-- a culture?
Let's say how do I
set up my team so
that we can have a good chat.
What can we-- remind
me of your name, sir.
AUDIENCE: Brian.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Brian, yeah.
How can I set up my team so we
can have a good chat, Eldridge
Cleaver style?
I'm not trying to trick anybody.
Alina has got-- Alina knows.
AUDIENCE: So this makes
me think of improv.
There's the yes and rule, where
you're basically like, yes,
and then you have
to build up on it.
You can't ever say
no and just stop.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Right.
So I'm not saying no, but.
I'm saying yes, and.
So maybe one of the ways
we can have a good chat
is to use some yes anding.
So I want to talk about--
here's one of my--
I wish I would have
done this study.
I didn't, but I love it.
But you guys can
predict the results.
I want you to predict
which pair of people--
and imagine there were
several observations.
So we get newlywed couples.
Presumably, these people
love each other very much,
and they're going to spend many,
many years with each other.
But then in some sense,
our control group
is people who are
previously unacquainted.
Maybe they're people of the
same generation and background,
but they're previously
unacquainted.
And let's say they're
doing a negotiation,
or they have to
do a negotiation.
Which one of these
would you put your money
on for reaching a
win-win agreement?
And remind me of your name.
AUDIENCE: Ed.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Ed.
Where did you put your money?
Who's going to reach
the win-win outcomes--
the newlyweds or the
previously unacquainted folks?
AUDIENCE: No idea.
LEIGH THOMPSON: No idea.
Some of us-- yeah, oh, good.
Caroline is going
to come through.
AUDIENCE: I did this exercise
in the negotiation class,
and it was a friend versus a
classmate that you don't know.
And then when you
don't know, you always
reach an agreement
with the kids.
You're not afraid
to give and take.
There's no repercussions
for the relationship.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Right.
So am I to think, Caroline,
that you would actually
put your money on these people?
Because the newlywed
couples are going
to too quickly capitulate.
They're not going
to have the chat
that I was asking you about.
They're going to
say, yes, honey,
I think I can live with that.
They're going to do
what Nobel laureate Herb
Simon calls satisficing--
I'm OK with that.
It's fine with me.
So that's exactly what happened.
The previously
unacquainted people
were much more likely to reach
the win-win, elegant outcomes
because the newlywed couples
took the low-hanging fruit.
AUDIENCE: I think
that the results would
differ if it was not newlywed.
I think that the results
would differ if it was more--
LEIGH THOMPSON:
Old, married people.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Old, married
people who are just saying--
and that would be an
interesting study.
I'm not sure that they
would reach the win-win.
They might reach
the win or lose.
But I think this is interesting.
They deliberately use newlyweds,
because I want to keep it good.
I want to agree with her.
They're in the honeymoon stage.
I think that that's where
the term comes from.
We're in the honeymoon stage.
So what I want to
do now is I want
to get back to something that
I asked Boris and I asked
all of you guys.
So how do you create a team,
how do you create a culture
where we can have a good chat?
And so companies need to
establish what we call
boxing rings and campfires.
A boxing ring means
that we can have
the tough conversations
and the debate,
but it's not going
to get personal.
We might even end up at the
common area, at the campfire.
I actually-- when
I coach teams, I
tell them disagree
about something
in your first meeting.
So I worked with
a team recently.
And they decided-- you know
that show "Undercover Boss?"
So we just picked
something innocuous.
We just said, look.
Everybody has heard
of "Undercover Boss."
Do you think it's a
good show or a bad show?
Some people think
it's a bad show.
Some people said I
think it's a good show.
Let's debate about something
that's not the big kahuna.
Because when we have to
debate about the big kahuna,
we can look back and say we've
already done this before.
We've already had a
spirited discussion.
Leaders practice debate
and have ground rules.
So I have a woman in my class.
She's actually in a
pharmaceutical company,
not that that matters.
She came up to me, and she said,
Leigh, I think I'm going nuts.
I said, why are you going nuts?
She goes, in my
previous company,
the culture was very
much along the lines
that Caroline and Boris
were talking about.
People had spirited debate.
They challenged one another.
And for a variety of
reasons, in her new company,
everybody was too polite.
And I said, well, what
are you going to do?
She goes, well, I've
hired a debate coach.
Coach is going to
come in and teach us
how to have a debate
that separates
the people from the problem.
So I want to now talk about
finding your inner negotiator.
And I want to ask you guys--
and this is not a trick
question or anything.
What are the qualities of
an effective negotiator?
And I'm not trying to trick you.
Anything you say is going
to-- remind me of your name.
AUDIENCE: Deborah.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Deborah,
what are the qualities
of an effective negotiator?
AUDIENCE: Collaborative.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Collaborative.
AUDIENCE: Creative.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Creative.
Dimitri?
AUDIENCE: Polite.
LEIGH THOMPSON: What?
LEIGH THOMPSON: Polite.
Oh, I like that.
Boris?
AUDIENCE: I think the qualities
that [INAUDIBLE] goal and some
[INAUDIBLE] negotiation.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Goal focus,
that they're goal-focused.
They have targets.
Anything else, Dan?
AUDIENCE: Good listener.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Good listener.
OK.
So everything that you've said
is definitely on the list.
And we actually
consulted with, I think,
the world class negotiator,
Howard Raiffa of Harvard.
And this is his
list that he used.
And I'm kind of curious.
Oh, she's used different
color fonts there.
I can't imagine what he's doing.
These are all qualities
that I think you mentioned
or we would, in
spirit, agree with.
Anything you notice
about this list?
I'm just curious.
Maybe I am trying
to trick you now.
But not really.
Dan, do you notice
anything about this list?
For example, this
list versus this list?
Nikki sees things.
Alina sees things.
AUDIENCE: I feel like
the one on the left
is focused on what can I
get out of the negotiation.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Yes,
self-interested.
And the one on the
right would be--
AUDIENCE: How do I basically
work with my [INAUDIBLE]?
LEIGH THOMPSON: I think--
yes, it's much more
outward focused.
How can I be a win-win for you?
So now I'm going to ask the
loaded, loaded question.
Do you see any
gender issues here?
Stereotypes?
How about let's use that.
Do we say any gender
stereotypes here?
What do we see, Nikki?
AUDIENCE: The guys
are [INAUDIBLE] women.
LEIGH THOMPSON: Yes.
OK.
So what we did is
we took this list,
and we asked people to do the
uncomfortable task that I just
asked Nikki to do.
We said, look, all
political correctness aside,
just indicate which of these
are stereotypically male
and stereotypically female,
using society's stereotypes,
not yours.
And the results were as crystal
clear as you can imagine.
Most people said duh, these
sound like the stereotype
of what it's like to be a guy--
assertive, rational.
I'm not going to get emotional.
And the right-hand panel sounds
like stereotypical feminine,
even though, obviously,
we don't agree with it.
And you might be
saying I can't imagine
what point you're making now.
Well, then we did a study.
And I want you to ignore the
right side and stay over here.
So when we did a study,
we had very talented,
motivated young managers,
people MBA-bound
at very elite institutions,
do a negotiation
that was fairly high stakes.
I think it was a job simulation
that they took very seriously.
And what we found is
that if you look up here,
this should say
ambitiousness of targets.
How high did they
set their North Star?
What were they trying to
achieve in terms of a salary
or starting options, et cetera?
As you can see here, the
men set much higher goals
than the women.
This is men, this
is women, and this
is how ambitious is my target.
So the men set
much higher goals.
And what I want to
emphasize is that this
was a simulation where all
of the financial factors
were the same for both people.
Then what we did is we
did the exact same study.
People had to do this high
stakes job simulation.
But right before
they negotiated,
everybody read a very
short page of information
in which we took this column.
We said just want you
to know that negotiation
experts believe that
these qualities are
important for being
a good negotiator.
Otherwise, I keep repeating
everybody did the same dang
thing.
And what we found when we
used the positive female
stereotype--
all of a sudden, the women are
setting really high stretch
goals.
The financial factors in the
negotiation did not change.
But somehow, when
we, in some sense,
affirmed the female
stereotype-- again,
it was a stereotype--
the women did better.
Now, you might be
saying, goals, schmoals.
What happened in their
employment packages?
Well, as you can see here--
ignore this junk.
In the control condition, the
way to read these weird data
is that the higher the bar,
the higher the northbound bar,
men did better than
women, because we actually
had them negotiating across
the table with each other.
When they had read about the
positive female stereotype,
the women actually did better.
So our take away
message is something
as subtle as
reminding people what
are the qualities
of a good negotiator
can have a dramatic
impact on setting goals
and actually how I choose
to use the information
in the situation.
And I close with another study.
This is the one that's
kind of over the top here.
This is what we call
the gorilla effect.
And I'm trying to show a
gorilla in the background here
that's not coming through.
We had a control group.
We just said do a negotiation.
It's high stakes.
Good luck.
It's going to mean a lot.
We had a unisex group.
In other words,
we said, actually,
negotiation, Dan, really
involves good judgment, sense
of humor, patient and prepared.
In other words, that
sounds like everybody.
And then we had a gorilla group.
And in the gorilla
group, we said, well,
there are sex differences
in negotiation.
And what we found, in
some sense, surprised us.
We found that the women did
the best in the gorilla group.
In other words, the higher
bars indicate that women
performed better than men.
And I'm curious-- do you guys
have hypotheses about why
that might be the case?
AUDIENCE: Because you're
so accustomed to proving
stereotypes wrong.
LEIGH THOMPSON: That's good.
Say it again.
AUDIENCE: If we're accustomed
to trying to prove stereotypes.
LEIGH THOMPSON: I think
that that's brilliant.
So in other words, you
give me some stereotype,
guess who's going to show you
that that's dead wrong right
now.
So in other words, when we
gave women the tip off that,
you know what, there
are gender differences,
their response was not today.
So we think that that's
kind of interesting.
And so one of the things
that we're doing--
and I'm going to try to close
very soon-- one of the things
that we're doing in our
research with gender
at the negotiation
table is we're
looking at holding constant
the financial information,
it's really about how am I
going to use that information,
and what are the expectations
I have of myself.
So to come full circle
here, we talk in the book
about a lot of these traps.
And again, the whole
idea is that a lot
of what we're doing
in our companies--
90% of what we're
doing is probably
working toward great ends.
But sometimes, when
we take some of these,
it can work against us.
And I just want
to mention that we
have a MOOC at Kellogg, Massive
Online Open Enrollment Course.
This is the free
login information.
So if you're interested in
negotiation and teams and a lot
of the things that
we've talked about,
this is the
information for that.
And I just wanted to take a
minute-- thank you guys so
much for sharing your input.
It means a lot.
And I hope our paths
cross many, many times.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]